I know what my father was what he did I
know the Mad King earned his name kill
every Targaryen get my answer
everyone who wasn't
is an enemy
so Ilyn bring me his head see that sword
[Music]
it's called hearts bein been in our
family for 500 years
it's Valyrian steel only a handful of
them left in the world supposed to go to
my firstborn son after I die to him he
will never wield that sword what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones season a
prediction in one of my recent videos I
talked about the Valyrian steel dagger
which is also known as the cat's ball
dagger the reason why I wanted to make
that one was because I rarely ever talk
about that weapon which leads me to
today's video Hart's Bane is another
Valyrian steel weapon that I don't
discuss that often I did make a video
about this sword during season 7 but
that was almost a year ago and I know I
have a lot of new listeners since I made
that prediction I think this is
something worth discussing because I
believe this Valyrian steel sword still
has a part to play in the Great War a
few different things happen during
season 7 that leads me to believe this
great sword will be seen again and it
couldn't have come at a better time
considering the night King and his army
of the Dead are making their way south
Hart's Bane has been the ancestral
Valyrian steel sword of house Tarly for
over 500 years and this sword finally
made its introduction into the show
during season 6 at the end of season 5
Samwell Tarly left the Nights Watch to
go to the Citadel Sam was planning on
becoming the next maester for the Nights
Watch at Castle black but most
importantly he was going to the Citadel
in hopes of finding some information
that could help them defeat the night
King as we all know Sam and Gilly
stopped at Sam's home in Horn Hill where
they had a very unpleasant dinner with
his father randyll Tarly Randall did his
best to embarrass Sam in front of
everyone and this is when he reminded
Sam of their family's sword hearts pain
this sword was meant to be passed down
to Randall's oldest son which is Sam but
he made it very clear that Sam would
never carry this sword this was not the
kind of reunion that Sam had hoped for
but he wasn't surprised because his
father has always been an [ __ ]
after dinner Sam knew that he could not
leave Gilly in the baby around his
father so all three of them left in the
middle of the night but not before Sam
could steal his family's ancestral
Valyrian steel sword off the mantle mine
looks better on you anyway that's your
father's sword it's my family sword well
he come for it completely well joy given
who Sam's father is everyone was sure
that he would go looking for Sam and his
sword he knew Sam was heading to the
Citadel but for whatever reason he never
went looking for him in fact the sword
was never mentioned again almost as if
it never happened at this point Sam can
do whatever he wants with the sword
because he no longer has to worry about
his father coming to find him after the
field of fire 2.0 Daenerys burnt Randall
and dicken Tarly alive for refusing to
bend the knee so this means Hart's bane
now belongs to Sam but what does he plan
on doing with it I think there were a
few clues in season 7 that hint at what
Sam may end up doing with hearts pain
when Sam was still at the Citadel the
arts maester received a raven from
Winterfell in the note said bran stark
had seen the army of the Dead marching
to eastwatch-by-the-sea but none of the
maesters took the warning very seriously
Sam tried to explain that what bran was
saying was the truth Sam even admitted
that he had seen the army of the dead
for himself but it wasn't quite enough
to convince the maesters that were stuck
in their ways Sam said they needed to
get every maester to search the library
to look for things about the long night
in hopes of finding some answers about
how to defeat the dead but once again
this fell on deaf ears
so instead Sam put his own plan into
action
once again Sam Gilly and the baby left
in the middle of the night but before
they left Sam had to steal something
again just like he did before he left
his house
Sam went into the library and took all
kinds of books and documents so that
could potentially give him answers about
the night King when Sam packed up their
carriage to leave you could see that he
still had hearts bein with him wrapped
up in the same blanket he had before so
the sword is in Winterfell with Sam and
Gilly I highly doubt that they had been
having Sam carry around this sword just
for shits and giggles the North will be
ground zero for the Great War and it's
no coincidence that all of the magical
swords will be in the North at the same
time heart's pain will be put to good
use in some way the Valyrian steel
dagger popped back up in the North right
before the battle was going to kick off
and Jaime Lannister is bringing the
other half of ice so we should see all
of these weapons play their part when
they need them the most one thing I am
wondering is what could possibly be in
all of those books and documents Sam
took from the Citadel is it possible
that Sam finds something on one of those
pages that gives him an idea of what to
do with hearts Bane I know we've all
been wondering if someone will ever
discover the methods to making Valyrian
steel could Sam possibly have that
information with him and he doesn't even
know it yet you also have to consider
what type of sword hearts Bane is hearts
Bane is a two-handed great sword which
means it's very big given the size of
hearts Bane it could easily be melted
down and made into more than one weapon
all you would need is someone that knew
how to reforge it and if they were going
to have anyone do this Gendry would
probably be the man for the job
Gendry disappeared from multiple seasons
but since they brought him back you have
to assume he will have a role to play in
the endgame this is interesting because
Sam and Hearts Bane are now in
Winterfell in Gendry is on his way there
- and he also have to keep in mind the
only reason why Davos went looking for
Gendry in the first place was because he
knew John was going to need blacksmiths
to turn all the dragon glass into
weapons Davos told ginjury he was
sending him to Winterfell to work in
their forges but as we all know
Gendry just couldn't keep his mouth shut
Gentry did end up revealing his identity
to John and he ended up going along with
them on their mission beyond the wall
but now that their mission
/ gang jury will resume his role as one
of the blacksmiths in Winterfell now I
know what some of you may be thinking
now that John has all of this dragon
class do they even need hearts pain
since dragonglass kills White Walkers -
that is a very valid point because you
don't need as much Valyrian steel when
you have a mountain of dragonglass
but you have to think of it like this
why would they have Sam steel this sword
and not put it to good use it would
completely defeat the purpose of Sam
taking it he obviously took it because
he knew it would be needed but on the
other hand I don't actually think Sam is
gonna be the one to use the sword
himself now I know Sam was able to kill
a white Walker back in season 2 but
let's be honest he kind of got lucky
it's not like he went toe-to-toe with
the white Walker he actually just
stabbed him in the back fighting a white
Walker face-to-face is a completely
different story and I doubt it's
something Sam wants to do I personally
think Sam will let someone else carry
hearts Bane or he will turn it into
several weapons if that's even possible
I can't guarantee if Gendry has the
ability to do this or not but I don't
think it's out of the realm of
possibility demand again sure he worked
for was named table Beaumont and in the
bulks he knew how to rework Valyrian
steel he was actually the same person
who turns the ice into two swords and
since Gendry worked with him for several
years there is a slight chance that
ginjury may have learned this skill from
him but they could just be waiting to
reveal this information in the final
season I don't think there are any
coincidences in this story only a
handful of people know how to reforge
Valyrian steel and Gendry just happened
to work for one of the men that did
George probably added that little layer
that way he could use it later on in the
story but this is just my opinion I know
most people don't agree with that
however I only give it a fifty-fifty
chance to happen in this show but in the
books I feel pretty confident it's going
to happen eventually even though I don't
think Sam will carry the sword himself I
will admit that there is a chance that
he could maybe he does it out of spite
or out of pride because his father told
him he never would Jon Snow has one hell
of a Suicide Squad ready to fight beside
him but the only problem is Jon is the
only one that had
of Valyrian steel weapon John has all of
these great sword fighters in the north
but they aren't properly equipped
I mean sure they could use a dragon
glass dagger but a swordsman needs a
sword in Hearts Bane is the perfect
weapon to carry into battle against the
army of the dead and you're not just
going to have some random solider using
hearts bane
a sword like this needs to be in the
hands of one of the main characters
John has Valyrian steel Arya has
Valyrian steel jamie has Valyrian steel
and Brienne has Valyrian steel
beric Dondarrion already has a flaming
sword so that leaves only a few top
fighters that could be worthy of using
hearts pain you have tormund Giantsbane
Jorah Mormont and the Hound these three
men would be my three picks if anyone
was going to use the sword since Hart's
Bane is a two-handed great sword The
Hound would probably be able to carry it
and swing it the easiest since he is so
big and strong but Sam has had no
interactions with him at all he might
not be willing to just hand it over to a
stranger but that doesn't mean the Hound
won't get it because when Sam sees him
he might just hand it over
also the Hound did say he always wanted
some Valyrian steel so perhaps he
finally gets his wish but I don't think
it's as likely as one of these other
candidates
tormund could easily do some damage with
it and he doesn't know Sam from their
time spent together at Castle black
but tormund doesn't typically carry a
sword he uses a different type of blade
although I am sure he would love to use
some Valyrian steel I mean who wouldn't
want to in my opinion I think Jorah
Mormont has the best chance of using
hearts bane Sam immediately had some
respect for Jorah simply because of who
his father was this was one of the
reasons why Sam wanted to help save
Dora's life in the first place and this
is when these two started to build a
friendly relationship with one another
he father saved me more than once it's
the least I could do oops a possible
cross again
I hope they do
not only did Sam and Jorah become
friends but Jorah is also a very
competent swordsman although he has
passed as prime John Snow now carries
house Mormons ancestral Valyrian steel
sword John did try to give it back to
Jorah but he did not want it but perhaps
Jorah could still end up using a
Valyrian steel sword if Sam would allow
him to carry it into battle
I think Hart's Bane would be deadlier if
it were in the hands of the Hound but I
could see Sam letting Jorah use it
before he would let the Hound use it but
I could be wrong about that there is one
other thing I want to mention about
hearts Bane before I end the video the
name of this sword itself could indicate
that it has a big role to play in the
end it might be too obvious for it to be
true but since it's called hearts Bane
you have to wonder if it will be plunged
into someone's heart
maybe it's given that name because in
order for the swords full powers to be
activated it needs to pierce a heart
perhaps this is the sword that is needed
to kill the night's king
we know he has dragonglass in his heart
so maybe heart's pain needs to be
plunged into his heart to counteract the
dragon glass that is giving him all of
his powers maybe that's a little bit too
tinfoil e for some of you but another
possibility is maybe hearts pain can be
plunged into the heart of us Ariane I
don't know if it would kill the dragon
or not but it could at least do some
significant damage
now this next scenario is a potential
spoiler so please proceed with caution
because if it does happen to be true it
would be a very big spoiler now
according to the plot league that I read
on my channel it says hearts Bane will
be the sword that is used to fulfill the
Nissa Nissa prophecy it says Sam will
hand Hearts Bane to John and he will
plunge it into Melisandre's horror
because Melisandre was trying to kill
baby Sam now some of you should know
that I do believe Melisandre is nice and
Nisa I did make a theory video about
that and I showed a bunch of evidence
and texts from the books but I am not so
sure of hearts Bane will be the sword
that is needed I suppose it could be but
I don't know how much of that plot lake
is even accurate I won't go too far down
that rabbit hole but I thought I should
at least mention that since I am making
a video about this sword like I said
earlier
I still believe it has a part to play
but let me know what you think
put all your thoughts on this down below
I want to thank you all so much for
watching the video and I also want to
thank all of my new patreon supporters
there were about five or six new people
that signed up yesterday and I cannot
thank you all enough I really do
appreciate that because it helps a lot
anyways I hope everyone has a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]